[Musique]
quelques très peu de couleurs une
simplicité qui attire l'oeil sur le
portrait et c'est le visage de jean
dujardin qui apparaît l'inspiration soul
in detroit la puise dans le monde
artistique
le choix des artistes fait vraiment par
rapport à mon inspiration est mon
inspiration je la puise dans la musique
donc c'est un son une chanson qui va
vraiment me faire qui va me parler qui
va m'emmener dans un univers propre à
moi une atmosphère et qui va me donner
l'envi de bas par exemple dessinée
samuel l jackson
joey starr certains utilisent la
peinture d'autres le crayon la jeune
trappistes ne se sépare jamais de son
stylo bille de son marqueur et de ses
écouteurs
[Musique]
j'ai pas mal d'années derrière moi de
cours d'art etc
j'ai déjà une bonne base et après avec
cette base je m'amuse et tout effet
voilà au stylo bille j'y vais en one
shot
c'est des choses de base simples qu'on
trouve de partout et je trouvais ça
important jeu ce monde de montrer ce que
j'étais capable de faire et de voilà 2
d'arriver à exprimer mes émotions à
travers des outils du quotidien
huit portraits sont actuellement
exposées à la mairie ce de trappes toute
une saison pour découvrir un talent 9
qui transparaît derrière des trait de
stylo maîtrisé